well the sudden closure of a large
wedding dress retailer has left many
brides to be scrambling to find a dress
in time for their big day Alfred Angelo
filed for chapter 7 bankruptcy on Friday
it closed all 61 of its stores just
before two of its most popular wedding
months August and September mega lovers
at an Alfred Angelo store in Cherry Hill
New Jersey to show us how the sudden
collapse is impacting plans for
countless weddings meg my heart goes out
to so many of these women so many be on
a good morning the bankruptcy also
caught many Alfred Angelo employees by
surprise across the country distraught
Brides have been coming to stores like
this one trying to get the dresses
they've paid for or put a deposit down
on many left empty-handed where's my
dress from California do I need to start
looking for another dress to Iowa every
Brides worst nightmare
to Indiana really screwed everybody over
brides felt jilted their wedding dresses
locked behind closed doors
Erin Casey bought her Alfred Angelo
dress last month I loved it it was the
first dress I tried on Casey paid more
than $1,200 for her dream dress
now she's worried she won't wear it down
the aisle in December I've tried calling
the store but it goes straight to
voicemail and voicemail is full in court
papers Alfred Angelo estimates its
assets at ten to fifty million dollars
but says it owes fifty to 100 million to
as many as twenty five thousand
creditors and customers the Florida
based retailer has been in business for
more than eight decades
last Monday its Board of Directors
authorized the chapter 7 bankruptcy
filing the first step towards
liquidating the company it suggests that
they think that there's no way to save
the business at all bankruptcy law
professor Stephen Levin says the brides
with the best chance of getting their
money back are those who already paid
for their dresses those dresses are
arguably theirs and they should be
entitled to them of course whether that
can all be sorted out in time for their
wedding is a big question
some of Alfred Angela's competitors have
stepped in giving away sample dresses or
offering discounts for them to just kind
of drop this news overnight
it's a shame on you moment now brides
who paid for their dresses with a credit
card can ask their banks for their money
back in a statement to customers Alfred
Angelo wrote we deeply apologize for the
inconvenience and hardship resulting
from this event we greatly appreciate
your patience Jeff make thanks very much
can only imagine that's good that other
retailers are jumping in those
discounted prices absolutely